es el tapón del Darién y es considerada
una trampa mortal una selva de 266
kilómetros atravesada por ríos y sus
corrientes y subidas de nivel también
con grandes peligros como animales
salvajes y mafias pero la desesperación
y la búsqueda de una mejor vida lo
convierten en una transitada vía más de
2.500 personas pueden llegar a cruzarlo
cada día el Darién está ubicado en la
frontera entre Colombia y Panamá y la
mayoría de los migrantes que lo cruzan
son venezolanos algunos proceden del
mismo país otros aprovechan sus ahorros
de años siendo migrantes en otros países
para poder viajar hasta Estados Unidos
los que logran cruzarlo respiran cuando
llegan al retén de la comunidad indígena
de canal membrillo después de días
caminando por fin reciben atención antes
de seguir en su ruta hacia Estados
Unidos
muchos muertos muchas montañas muchos
ríos que se llevaron a mucha gente
corriente
doctor horrible es una experiencia muy
dura no se la recomiendo a nadie de
verdad que no De verdad que cada quien
arregle su vida por por un futuro pero
de verdad no le recomiendo a nadie que
se venga por la selva es muy fuerte muy
duro este sufrimiento no garantiza el
éxito y todavía quedará por delante un
largo camino hacia Estados Unidos donde
sesión atrapados de forma irregular
serán devueltos entre octubre de 2021 y
agosto de 2022 más de 150.000 migrantes
venezolanos fueron detenidos en la
frontera Sur
[Aplausos]